heck happened with my microphone
here that was weird Okay
um we got some stuff to do today we got
some stuff to
do I think I'm feeling good um there are
a couple last problems that I have to
solve essentially right now and then we
will be oops and then we should be set
on the whole structure for how we add
new environments to puffer just a couple
last things that I need to solve here
and we should be set
um actually we have to solve a few
things today in order for that to happen
um and I think really the thing that I
want to do today is I want to be done
with the full end to end in uh way in
which we make new environments for
puffer and we make that process simple
and
easy that's what I want to do right now
I don't think it should be that hard I
think we've already solved the hard
stuff there's just a little bit of
organization and then one kind of
technical thing I got to figure out
let's start with the hard
problem so here's the issue right now
let me show this
this is the binding for breakout right
now so this stuff
here the reason that this needs to be
kept is because we create the
environment inside of
reset that's the reason this needs to be
kept
the reason that we have to make the
environment inside of
reset is that puffer lib uh the way
puffer lib allocates
buffers is a little bit weird
the reason in fact that we have to do
this at
all is right
here so technically speaking
here most of this stuff is supposed to
be
redundant really the only thing that we
should need to
know we need to know the number of
Agents don't
yeah that's
standard we need to know the observation
and action
spaces but this buffer stuff this
emulated this done all this stuff should
be able to be deleted single action
space single OB space this should all be
able to be
deleted M agents yeah all this stuff
render mode like a lot of these things
should just be
handled reason I didn't have this at the
moment is I didn't want to have I mean
if we look at this Base
Class this doesn't do anything right
it's just like this
silly base that I use just to check the
type
because I wanted this to be an API not
like a base class right cuz Jim has way
too much garbage essentially as part of
the base
class and I wanted this to not have to
do
that so let me think about that let me
think about that
the tricky part
here is
handling observation action know buffer
part let me check the
vectorization I haven't looked at this
code in a while maybe maybe I'll uh I'll
think of something here that I missed
before welcome YouTube
folks we're making progress today we're
going to make this
work it's been too long that there's
just been like this last little bit of
Jank with puffer cuz I've been building
Sims and we really I want this to be
gone
here you see we make the environment
right we make all the
environments and then we have assign
buffers this thing here which gets
called in
reset and they get made right
here and if you do this
multiprocess then um they get assigned
externally
this so the reason I did it this
way there are a lot of different things
that can happen here
and basically the the difficulty here of
making all this
simple is I want to make it very easy
for people to design environments of
various levels of
optimization I want basically like
however much effort you want to put into
making an environment puffer is going to
give you the best return on investment
regardless so if you just want to make a
python M puffer should make that easy
and fast right if you want to make like
a vectorized python M puffer should make
that easier easy and
faster if you want to do cython puffer
will make that even faster and then if
you want to do c you get
everything and because of
that we have this serial
thing serial assumes that you could want
to
run you could want to run the loop over
environments in Python that is why this
thing
exists if we assume that every
environment has the ability to create
multiple copies of itself and manage
itself then we do not need
idea we do
a native Veen
format it doesn't need
cereal does that make it harder for
people
though say when you write custom M's you
also have to handle the loopover
environments that does kind of make it
hard for people doesn't
it it adds extra
logic who does it make it hard
for it makes it hard
for a user that who wants to implement
custom
environments who wants to use our native
a but doesn't want to do scyon
RC does that user
exist I'm trying to think if that user
even
stuff I don't know if it's the lack of
whiteboards in my recent
work but um keep going back to drawing
stuff so
like the way we have this now right that
we have
multi-processing is the main
box and then inside of
this you do they're like your cores or
cereal and then inside of this you've
got
emulation really it should be like this
there a lot of these
so this is the standard puffer
model you have multi-processing you have
the ability to run multiple environments
per core using the serial implementation
so you kind of it's kind of funny that
you run Vector on Vector but it makes
sense because you need a way to do this
Loop is what serial
does serial does that Loop for you
and the reason that serial has to do
this Loop for you is that the emulation
layer is not a vectorized API the ve the
emulation layer is standard
API gym
API it's kind of funny that that API
even exists though isn't it
useless like when the heck do you ever
want when do you ever use the gym
API instead of
VC I guess we need it for compatibility
with other libraries at least until
puffer's
bigger yeah we don't want to break
compatibility with other stuff that's
kind of one of the nicest things with
puffers it's just compatible with
everything so technically there's a
layer of infrastructure we could cut out
completely like if we just said hey
there is no gym API there is no petting
zoo API there's one API it's the VC
API you know you can use the VC API it
has multiple backends right it can be
serial or multiprocess that cuts out a
layer that cuts out a
layer we're not ready to do that yet
but we can think about
it so what if instead right we have
native as a back end what if we just do
like
and then when you write your custom Ms
you just write them as a
native
environment the native API the native
API is the VC
API and then you can run multiple like
you can run one of these on each process
and you're good that's all you ever need
ever that's kind of nice isn't it
wrapper that
does what native to gymnasium or
something like that
zoo that we don't have to do
today that we don't have to do
today it's not a high priority to
introduce compatibility rappers for
people to be able to take our like
beautifully optimized environments and
run them way slower
right might be important for getting
some s sp3 users to try out puffer in
the like longer term but
um I mean that's a dumb thing to do in
my mind right rappers that slow stuff
down for compatibility with slower
Tools Plus these things should be able
to support a v
anyways do I lose anything by doing this
I don't think I
do I don't think I lose a single thing
by doing
this I guess technically it makes you
have to it makes you guaranteed have to
handle the loop um in the environment
itself but you want to do that anyways
don't
straightforward and technically you
don't even have to do a loop if you want
your native M to like not support
that but puffer makes it easy because
the native M gives you uh the
observation buffers and such already so
that's the advantage
okay so this is a good idea if I can
make it
simple can I make it
simple what's native
here I hate the idea of subclassing this
so much but I'm trying to think of
another way of doing
knit I thought about that
maybe it's time to do
it basically I'm trying to figure out is
where all these shared memory buffers
need to be
passed I think the reason that I didn't
do this
before uh I didn't want to do it that
way before was because let's say that
you want to like make a standalone set
as a
test then you need to allocate those
buffers which doesn't make any
sense subclassing fixes this but I
really don't want to do that unless it's
absolutely
on maybe it is a subass
angle
[Music]
because is a wrapper angle or a subass
angle
regardless just to check the type of it
doesn't
it I mean technically I don't have to
have a base class I could literally just
say yeah you write it this is the
API to
follow it's like an it could be a purely
abstract based
it is kind of awkward now that I'm
looking at
it the way multiprocessing has to
interact with this
am I going to bananas
here the question I'm trying to figure
out right is like multiprocessing at the
moment it spawns several processes duh
and each of those is Cal each Cal
materal can contain many
environments what I could do
instead actually don't know if that
makes it any easier I guess it replaces
the Cal inside of multiprocessing with a
anything I mean it's slightly simpler
code Maybe
out I guess this is a pretty easy check
right right here
you just have to add I'd have to add
something right here to see if it's a
native environment or not
this can have a freaking make function
though that's
annoying I guess it's just a a Boolean
that we passed from the driver and is
native so lot of stuff to change I think
we could do it right now
it and then the benefit to this hold on
let me make sure there's benefit
is this still going to be a rapper class
though
this is still going to end up being a
rapper class isn't
it it's too much
garbage too much garbage
the thing I'm stuck here
is whether I want this to just
be you accept the evil of having a base
class and you directly subclass
native and then your TCH stack it just
becomes multiprocess of native done
multiprocess of native done nice shallow
stack all
right
versus we literally have puffer M just
be a strict API it's just like abstract
base class and then this thing wraps it
well how does this play with
buffers how does this play with buffers
let me
see reset assigns
buffers
M's okay they don't want to you don't
want to pass the shapes
here I
see cuz otherwise you have to pass all
this stuff from the main process all
this stuff you got to pass it
this is so silly
though isn't this kind of
silly look you do this driver M you get
all this
data right and then you basically
recompute all of
I mean
regardless I think I can get this if I
want it right if I want to have this
data available before I make
this before I make these environments I
can have it cuz I get it off the driver
Ms at least I assume
so so
we pass the
slice this buffer creation goes up here
we pass the slices
up there needs to be a default way of
creating
buffers that's the tough
part the default way of creating buffers
has to propagate all the way down to the
environment
mean yeah it's just it's not not worth
it because
like you f so I F so hard to keep this
thing
flat the reason I don't like subclassing
at all wherever possible especially not
in user space is subclassing implies
complexity if you think about it right
if I give you a class or if I give you a
function everything you need to know is
contained in that piece of code if I
give you something that is like API
where you have to subass now what that
says is that hey there's more stuff here
it's like black magic that you don't
know about that's hidden inside of this
whatever this super class
is so I really really try to avoid that
whenever I
can I mean to the extent that I would
rather duplicate little bits of code
here and
there just to have it be
self-contained so like if I say I
categorically am not going to let
subclassing be a
thing if I were to say
that
then how do we get the buffer
data in the environment how do we get
the buffer data
the problem
here maybe if I explain
here really what we want is we want to
be able to re make we want to be able to
make the environment right here in a it
not in reset
it's so easy if I were to just
subass right it's so
easy if I just
subclassed what is it that subclassing
gets
me it's so damn annoying to replace
it's
um it's really just the allocation of
these buffers
great just playing chest on another tab
does that
count you know I've been wanting to add
chess to this Library as a while for a
while now see if we can get
reinforcement learning to play
chess might be a little tricky but I
think in theory should be a lot easier
to learn than go even with the
additional technical
difficulties that'd be kind of
fun I am terrible at chess I can program
something that will I can program
something that will play chess better
than me very very easily it is much
easier for me to make something that
plays chess than it is for me to play
chess are you so may nerd oh
yeah oh yeah
I am a uh newly minted MIT PhD in
reinforcement learning and I am
currently attempting to fix the mess the
scientific field is in so this is just
live this is live Dev on exactly
that which involves a lot of code but
also a lot of me staring at code and
trying to figure out how I want to
design
things amb at Vandy very
I took a few MBA courses while I was at
uh MIT just cuz you know I had them
available there with
Sloan mainly just enough to be competent
on that side of things though no Tech is
my
27 that will be the average graduating
age if you do your PhD directly after
undergrad
this thing is just bothering
me I'll be
pilot I have no idea how you play chess
and type at the same time I don't know
probably a game I could
itself isn't that already a
thing I thought the autopilot already
lands the plane most of the time
now does but not
interesting you know the fun thing with
AI is um when you first designed systems
you have to have a human to take over
when the AI messes up but when the
systems get really good then the AI
takes over when a human messes
up bothers me so much that I can't
figure out a way to do this like I see
the way to it I just don't want I don't
like the
answer bothers
me it really shouldn't bother me that
much come to think of it
either coding looks like a really boring
job to
[Music]
me compared to anything else that requ
that is mainly typing on a keyboard
no but compared to anything that is is
not simply typing on a keyboard all day
maybe say at home and
type like to
travel can't say I like traveling much I
get plenty of exercise
though offsets all the the desk
work I think I'm just going to have to
do this the way I don't really want to
do it for now
work
yeah that's it's obnoxious but it'll
work hey what's up
I'm trying to strip the last bit of fat
out of the um the custom environment
stuff I'm trying to make it really easy
and I found a way to do it but it
involves I have to add a base class for
the uh the native environments like the
new SE environments the python rappers
they need a native a a base class and I
hate having to subass stuff I really
hate having to have any amount of
inheritance ever but like when I'm
thinking about it here there has to be
at least an abstract Base Class
anyways because if there isn't then you
can't tell that something is a native
environment it needs to just have like
that thing there just to signify it so
if we have to have that anyways I might
as well put just a little bit of stuff
in there to make it easier I
guess maybe that's
cope I can't think of a better way of
doing it though for
now this freaking buffer right
here this needs to have a way of being
allocated without the user having to put
this
here that's the main
thing I guess we just do
it
right let me make sure I'm not being
dumb and missing meetings because I had
a whole bunch of stuff let me just make
sure I'm not being dumb and missing
something I'm pretty sure I did my stuff
for today
I have been hacking on a Tic Tac Toom
now at around 1.1 mil SPS with some kind
of
stuff you know what's funny cuz I
actually I wanted to Tic Tac Toe EnV
because there was some guy on Twitter
saying that you can't solve tic-tac-toe
with RL which is
yeah so if you want to just go ahead and
uh run like just Auto solve Tic-Tac toe
I will gladly you know put put that as a
reply to what whoever the hell that was
on Twitter cuz it's like yeah RL should
just solve that game in like instantly
right it's very
easy first RL course was with tic taac
toe yeah it should like it should be
easy
right I don't know like people get these
really degenerate
ideas about a lot of stuff in RL like
like it not working or whatever and it's
always always because they have really
bad infrastructure that's just like
doing the wrong thing and doing it
slowly like there's some base the thing
is like with RL is there's some base
level of infrastructure you kind of need
in order to make everything easy and
then you can just solve anything with it
dqn code solve the m in 30 seconds yeah
it should
I mean it should be less than that with
puffer but yeah it's like a simple
little
environment hey we put whatever online
though I mean if you want to if you want
to do the the full
thing we'll just put whatever people
build on
here like we're just accumulating the
set of environments right here this one
was just uh contributed
yesterday are you still using a bun
220 uh on this or on puffer
tank let's check puffer
tank star the puffer by the way helps us
out a
22.4 on puffer tank I have no idea what
my local is but it's uh the Nvidia
container on 2204 for latest puffer
tank yeah let's actually get started on
this proper
implementation's really
messy learn what makes difference more
complex ounds yeah I mean we have way
better examples now if you look in the
dev Branch at breakout and pong they're
very simple welcome Spencer Spencer made
the connect 4M and I imagine there's a
Triad PR in the on the way triple Triad
PR actually this is good timing is there
PR I should merge on this right now cuz
if not I just figured out
um I kind of decided on the way that
we're going to strip the last little bit
of fat out of uh the puffer API stuff
for new
M's so that's happening today but I'll
gladly merge triple Triad first if you
have it
fresh one is
in let's do
right okay got
this got this
good try.
PI right
here you can't pass
um you can't pass by reference easily in
Python is the problem the way you do
that is by encapsulating an array cuz
python doesn't have the idea of a
pointer right it has pass by reference
pass by value and the arrays are pass by
value that's why you have to do this
slicing actually see this mis logging
thing here this is I'm pretty sure this
is
wrong I think if you don't pass a slice
well it depends on the dimensions of
this thing but if you don't pass a slice
it might not get copied over correctly
so I'd be careful with that it depends
on the dimensionality I believe so you
might be okay but you should be careful
with that
yeah it's weird so if you slice into an
array and it returns an INT it'll just
return the int by
value you have to make sure you're
getting a
y I told you about these uh pointers and
stuff but you can do this you know
later my recommendation is not to do
these types of things if you can avoid
it it actually will make your life
easier in some cases as well believe it
or
not like for
example these memory allocations here
this would just be one giant calic this
would be one calic this would be one
line all these things would be on
liners and then the freeze would also be
on
liners some additional init and reset
stuff is ends up being one line flat
indexing is kind of
nice this makes sense though I see how
you're doing this
things that can be improved is the deck
generation cards to start with a random
on both
sides did I tell you I think I told you
about the uh the MTG thing
right I'm talking with uh I'm talking
with an MTG guy on Friday who wants to
build like an MTG style rln and I also
have uh I have a you know a very capable
p PhD student I know who also wants to
do this and says that they he has got um
bandwidth to do this relatively
soon I'm absolutely sure they would be
more than happy to Loop you in as
well I mean this is straight engineering
work
right and I mean if you're just if
you're Dev in competent C code then
you've got the qualifications to
contribute
stuff there are a couple small things I
would suggest you know improving with
the uh the code here but it they're
relatively minor complaints I would say
uh I'll ignore the stalis ones cuz like
who cares but uh the the really big one
is the double and triple
pointers I mean that's not far off from
MTG
yeah I'll let me do the initial meeting
cuz I haven't met the guy
and then uh I will Loop you in and I'll
Loop the other PhD friend of mine
merge can you check the reward
Ving yeah but I can also I'll fix it in
the I'll fix it in the merge if I need
nice so one to five to select a card let
me
six anything better than six
there I don't know how it breaks
ties I actually have no intuition for
this game which is very kind of like
that's kind of funny to
huh I think I
win there we
go cool this is like a random opponent
or something though isn't
it nice game
we're going to have this on the website
in a few minutes
see if you can track down um South CX in
the Discord I haven't seen him in a
couple of weeks but he was doing a bunch
of cool
artwork I don't know where he went I
hope the guy is okay
yeah it's going to need some opponents
and
stuff I actually have no idea how hard
that game is like thinking off the top
of my head
I have no idea I have like no intuition
for how complicated that game is to
understand
download
Tri asset
okay and then this
is oh what did I do I was not paying
attention and I just freaking hold
tryad let's just not let's just not uh
invite
interesting ah it's
misspelled this is why we
go kind of
big not bad though
I do like
goes oh for
[Music]
tryad it's okay for
now we might change some
stuff let me make sure it's
online I mean we'll see
but
[Music]
um we also where you need to start
getting some policies playing these so
you can play against the policy I'll be
next boom there you go one minute
I've heard you're saying that you don't
care about sample efficiency but that
only makes case for where you don't have
access to a fast
simulator have you seen the iceberg
video I go over this in a lot of detail
it's uh you have to go you have to go
fast in order to make progress on those
M's basically so yes uh focusing on this
is how we get to More Sample efficient
stuff anyways
here we
go we've been
uh farming a bit of
5K right there's your environment online
well done thanks for the
um there cases in robotics where you
have to train your
robot yeah but Peter like I go through
this in the iceberg video like the tldr
on it is that like the whole field is
stuck and we're doing really bad science
because our M's are too slow to run
enough experiments and such so we just
don't run them so like half of all RL
results are just wrong like half of all
the conference papers being published
are just wrong it's like an absolutely
terrible situation and the only way that
we're actually going to fix anything is
by having these super fast environments
to test stuff prop uh properly and like
we will actually be able to discover
more sample efficient methods uh by
doing this but the thing is like we need
to to be able to run these comprehensive
experiments and it's just not possible
now like you never want to be in a
situation where in order to make
progress like you're limited on the
number of experiments that you can run
and that's just it's literally killed
the field like rl's been stuck since
2019 because of this so that's kind of
the idea here it's not that caring about
sample efficiency is dumb it's that the
way that it's been approached in the
field has caused lasting damage I cover
this much more eloquently in the video
um but that's like the quick
version anything else Spencer or should
I get stuck into this um these
environment
fixes for the uh like for the API
isn't standard practice to run 25 seeds
per
experiment people don't do that and also
25 seeds per experiment what about hyper
parameters you take your method you
compare to Baseline Baseline doesn't
have t hyper parameters you have tuned
hyper parameters you win 2 weeks later
somebody goes and tunes the hyper
parameters for the Baseline and now it
does three times better than yours this
happens RL hyper parameters can have a
two to threefold or more impact on
performance
uh without changing anything
else there are problems there are big
problems like for instance po Poo's been
benchmarked on a lot of different Atari
environments a ton of different times
right well why are puffers two to three
times better for a lot of the
environments we tuned hyper parameters
that's all we did it's very
also people are just straight up not
running 25 seats per experiment like if
your experiments take multiple days
you're not running 25 of
them well publishing without tuning
hyper parameter sounds kind of stupid
well it's not stupid though it's that
there're no resources right Labs don't
have hundreds of gpus and the stupid
like the experiments are so slow because
of the lack of focus on wall clock train
time that like the experiments take days
when they should take hours or maybe
even minutes
can you check on models.py update for M
training not certain we should change
OBS with the latest version in Dev uh
let me fix that
thing I should have done that last night
my bad
even when running experiments that take
days isn't it easily done by running
them on an HPC yeah if you have one like
this is where I would put my HPC if I
had one
right I mean I was at MIT and our
cluster was so garbage that I never even
used it we had no Hardware zero
zilch you think there aren't dozens or
hundreds of labs that similarly have
garbage
Hardware it's not a fun place to be in
you can run 100 experiments on a GPU on
a desktop then then we're talking right
I again guessed every un had a decent
clusterer
nope I was in a lab at Stanford the
resources sucked I was in a lab at MIT
the resources sucked
like what wait did I even change stuff
here I don't even see any commits on
in uni budget was spent on buying 50
workstations that in the background ran
scheduled Computing jobs one of those
labs had a GPU each for that purpose no
it didn't make things good
really well I guess the scheduled
Computing jobs no but 50 workstations is
solid um
if there if you have like a couple of
those allocated to each student you can
actually do
stuff what are MIT and Stanford doing
with all their money paying stupid
numbers of
admins um I don't know it's it's
embarrassing it's not better at most
other universities too it's not like oh
it's worse the better the university is
most people are just doing dumb things
with it like you can say like yeah
technically we've got gpus on paper
right but like you give all the grad
students pseudo access and you let them
abuse AFS and NFS and quickly like you
got a bunch of expensive paper
weights I'm actually kind of surprised
that didn't make things good because uh
we've got this is what we have for
puffer right now and this is way better
than anything I had at MIT we just got
we just bought eight
desktops and they're really
nice I mean we had some issues because
of the dumb Intel chip glitch this
generation but outside of that this has
been great
the background Ram scheduled Computing I
think the scheduled Computing jobs is
going to be the issue people mess up
scheduling a
lot esoteric knowledge students access
that
cluster yeah that's
ridiculous no no no no the way that you
can do this reasonably is you just buy
four of these per student and you're
done
right you just buy four or five or six
however many of these per student and
you're good PR
97 why does this say modified 3 weeks
ago then am I dumb
what are you making we're Devon puffer
lib we're doing ultra high performance
reinforcement learning you want a quick
demo of stuff puffer Dogg we got some
environments you can play around with
this one actually has some decent bosss
you can play against you're the yellow
snake we also got some fancier
stuff no it was 50 PCS with 150 students
enrolling to it each year many yeah no
that's ridiculous I mean that's just
like you have no Hardware right you
added a scheduler to solve a resource
scarcity problem that doesn't
work and also the other problem is that
you bought workstations those are marked
up like
double so you could have had good 100
100 or 150 desktops
rough I mean I literally was considering
like if I just buy 50 of these I think
we're kind of good the trick is we don't
have a scheduling system or anything on
these I just give people direct SSH
access to a couple boxes or however many
boxes um and I say okay you get these
boxes you get these boxes for now and
it's very very easy there's no like
[ __ ] extra scheduling software
there's no AFS there's no NFS uh the
only infra is like there is a shared
Docker image that we use as the base and
then you can spin up Docker on the
machines like when you boot in you get
booted directly into your Docker and if
you want to make other Dockers to try
stuff out you can do that but like
immediately you have instant setup it
takes literally five minutes to onboard
people it's like if you can't do the
fancy thing correctly just do the brain
dead thing it'll be better
uh oh I see it's because it's
from yeah cuz this is when the commits
were okay that's weird I didn't know
that GitHub does its dating that way
I can just go try to fix it real quick
as the other thing instead of reverting
it that would probably be better that
doesn't Kick the Can what's not what
doesn't work you have an example it's
like puffer or python
demo and connect for mode train this
doesn't work
you don't have to prefix stuff with my
that was just because there a name conf
oh I guess there is a name conflict with
open Spiel
mind yeah that's really
silly I don't know what the heck it is
with these universities I mean you when
you ask like what the money is being
spent on like they assess more than six
figures of cost per PhD student per year
so the money is going
somewhere not going into
Hardware okay found your bug let me
figure out what the heck this
is damn it
linky I swear I asked him to test this
this what's the difference between this
and just normal reinforcement
learning uh well puffer is very fast and
a lot simpler it's gener I mean what
What's Happening Here is this is me
trying to fix all the stuff that caused
pain and suffering throughout my PhD
this is me making things fast making
things simple and making things work on
much more interesting
oh I see why he did this
okay I see why he did
this kind of
weird let me figure
uh if I'm wrong here I'm pretty sure
this is linky's
no this is
default so
uh
linky damn it
all right let's actually fix the the
rest of the stuff
now I'm assuming you cannot hear desktop
audio
right I can mute it
regardless I'm going to just toss
something up on the background
done still answer questions and stuff
but
uh hold
on oops wrong
one we're going to fix some stuff today
all right let me grab uh let me grab a
drink and we'll be get ready to get
going on this I think it'll only take me
an hour to do this if I'm quick
here's the
plan we're going to make the V API the
native API work we're going to Port all
the environments to use it we're going
to clean some stuff up we going to go
from there there are a few other
structural changes I want to make but
we're going to start with
I have to also not break GPU
drive that's not hard
quars going to be
Stars this
property cuz you can't override
properties I'm pretty
right
oops for
mobs is there any reason we need this
otherwise I don't think so
this
reset
step
ready what is self. ready
uh this needs to
be
that's nice we get a reasonable error
that's what we
want so you go like this right num
Ms
agents I don't think we need n m we just
need n agents
right and then we'll get a different
error
right the [ __ ]
error and what do we have for reset and
step
here these are fine
yeah and now we get a reasonable
AR is exactly what we want we want users
to hit
this so we go like this
don't need
this literally don't need any of this
yeah you do need n
Ms that's
fine also this
is
okay is this thing actually already
running really that
easy cool
this will have to be updated a little
bit
here but this is fine for now
the heck s
Broadway
breakout okay this needs some sort
of reward
there's no reset in here
either little awkward
this is kind of
weird is it missing the
H is in the dotage
somewhere no
see I thought I had like a little piece
of C code somewhere here for
this Maybe
not maybe not
yeah it's not in C yet okay that was a
two do
okay hey
Nathan let me pause this a second and I
will tell
you so there's a lot of stuff that's new
um first of
all two new environments from
Spencer got Connect Four and also this
cool card game pretty sweet
if you play randomly it doesn't go very
well um and then also I figured out how
to trim the rest of the fat off of all
the binding layers so basically it's
going to be really easy and really
simple uh like the python to scon to C
line is going to be really really simple
I just need to finish coding it which is
what I've been doing now it's a little
bit
tricky um I'm not 100% satis ifed with
it but I think it's way better and it's
going to cut a lot of the pain points
and boil their plate off and really make
stuff a lot easier speed should be about
the same I don't think it's going to
have there's no overhead to it I don't
think it'll make anything really much
faster either um but it will make stuff
substantially
easier that's what I'm on at the
moment you make any progress on your
environment
trying to work on tactical let me know
how to trim it down and the code's going
to be basically identical it's just
going to fix um it's going to basically
you're going to be able to remove a
couple of the obnoxious like really long
init method signatures so The scon
Binding gets a little bit simpler um and
then like the weird buffer stuff and
some of the weird like magic variables
that you have to have in a knit for
puffer Ms to work aren't going to be
there just stuff like that basic
convenient stuff but uh you know it'll
make stuff look a lot smoother for the
least at the very
it' be so cool we have like tons and
tons of
these all right we go back to this any
if you have something to share on the
Tactical I'd be glad to take a look if
not uh code
the heck is wrong with this
oh
go. okay so here this is where reset
gets
on me make sure my brain dead self is
not missing
stuff there are way too many places
where I like contact people to schedule
meetings and they don't just all get
into my calendar
think I forgot a
binding
yep got
it
stats yeah this should be showing up in
stats oh cuz you're dumb
like I'm kind of curious wait does it
actually is this policy actually this
good
oh do I have
negative this is
negative yeah so this is what's
happening yeah it doesn't actually work
that fast that's okay it will work that
fast once we fix it
where's reset being
called uh from python right
now we're going to fix that but it's
still not going to be called
what happened
oh look at
this is very
weird PA
this okay so this plays right I
lose yeah
well let's also implement
the the close method
this is
good we need to fix buffers
works now in multiprocessing I guess in
serial EV
I just do Dash ve
native do
this is where you pass
it I guess I just have to add the native
option for
and now we actually get to get rid of
[ __ ]
code love doing that
that
nicer no longer need
this we
actually don't need this either
got
two
ah I think I made the API different for
this right
Beed seven got five what's the signature
that I missed mask I
think what else
terminals truncations Agent H there's a
lot of girl there's a lot of uh garbage
here
okay um we've got some progress
here I've got to go do a couple quick
things um and then I will be back in a
little bit not very long I don't know 20
30 minutes um and we'll finish this I
really want to have this thing done
today at least like a prototype of
it anyways I'll